what do you think are the biggest Fred's
most important threats to nowadays
civilization I think the biggest biggest
threat to our civilization is very much
tied in my judgment to the infinity of
human desire that hasn't found its
proper resting place and so kind of the
restlessness that characterizes us in
search for transcendence is transposed
onto created realities and we inevitably
end up in competitive relationships
investing the works of our hands and our
own lives with the kinds of meaning that
they cannot they cannot deliver I think
unless we learn that human beings cannot
live by bread alone we really cannot
understand sufficiently human beings we
really cannot save so to speak human
human beings and we are meeting here at
time that in Cleveland Ohio is the
convention of the republican party where
people are yelling that the political
opponent of the Democratic Party eluting
should be locked up and more of that
kind of things what's your take on the
political situation here in America
coming from Croatia and knowing a little
bit about a civil wars quite fearful
fearful about the situations recently
spoke in Munich and together for Europe
gathering of variety of Christian
communities and I opened my speech on
the square in in Munich with comment
that the situation in Europe today
reminds me a bit of the situation just
before the civil war in form of Eva
slavia where you had this enraged sense
of Rage that has amassed itself and was
highly oppositional claiming its own
identities and wanting to to move move
apart cert itself over against others
very little interest in in deliberation
about common common future what one
finds in many places in Europe today
what fun fine certainly at Republican
convention right now is a red-hot anger
that is highly oppositional that knows
how to destroy the opponent but does not
how to that end therefore knows also how
to build tall walls but does not know
how to build bridges as it turns out we
live in a highly pluralistic societies
and without ability to build bridges we
are unable to survive and I'm afraid
that in situation which we find
ourselves today this heightening of
rhetoric of angry rhetoric of destroying
the enemy will in fact undermine our
ability to to live together as a as a
nation highly highly polarized we need
to heal the nation rather than build for
their walls that separate